hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
today it is an Indiana Jones themed
episode so we figured it'd be
appropriate to bring back the one member
here who has the same last name as the
doctor himself welcome back clinta Jones
Thank You Nico thank
clana I'll take it you know it's it's
it's Clos as you guys can get to you
know pronouncing your name correctly
yeah or you know bringing in someone
from the
[Music]
movie God what a
shot I love the original Indiana Jones
movies they have a certain like
scariness to them that like 88s films
have how is he still alive this some
dark magic oh man this is my childhood
they're just great movies they're
impeccably filmed Spielberg is one of
the best directors of all time he's such
a good visual Storyteller it sounds like
though in your world Indiana Jones is
only three movies long for me personally
for me personally it's a Trilogy well in
today's video it's five movies long
let's do it let's do it they did the to
they did a crazy practical effect here
wa this is so insane this is the best
daging I've ever seen in my entire life
that was good I'm excited to talk about
all this cool stuff come along with us
as we explore
[Music]
together oh
God man this is a movie at spawn a th
Wolfenstein sequels yes yes return to
Castle Wolfenstein is basically just the
movies in a nutshell but it's about to
go down right now bellock uh he cracked
open the the old Arc of the
Covenant o that's not good I love this
is that
fog that subtle lens flare yeah I'd be
out of there if I was the soldiers are
those ghosts coming out of it oh yeah to
be it's Moses himself me the integration
of like the ghost effects the smoke
effects so perfect I'm getting
Ghostbuster Vibes yeah major Ghostbuster
Vibes and lots of like painting on film
[Music]
W it's like the one CG looking
ghost all right make an emoji face look
like a
muppet wow so cool like go through their
clothes and you can see the suspenders
is that all like just hand tracked
painting here we go here we
go God what a
shot
cop out
though it's like we have two incredible
Prosthetics I don't blow the third one
up I love how they have the fire and
everything like following the flow of
the the set yeah Cloud effects wait how
the heck did they make that cloud that's
crazy right every single element here is
a practical thing that had to be filmed
or painted by hand like there's the only
two ways to generate an image it's
either take a picture of something or
paint
it that Landing perfect he's
like whoa was there that was a cross
fade you're right that was a cross fade
those are two shots right there it's a
shot in Reverse cutting to a normal shot
so the jet is like sucking in and then
when the lid lands it cuts to a normal
shot playing forwards so the smoke
continues to move off the thing as it
flows off of it there's a moment where
lightning like shoots out oh yeah yeah
they all get lit up yeah are those
practical lights in them yes really yeah
they looks really nice it'd be really
hard to paint that and that's the thing
that they were saying Nico was that it
wouldn't look good if we like painted
the light in like we need some uh
interaction between the light and the
characters and the environment so do
they have like light bulbs just like in
their shirt ready to be turned on and a
wire running down their pants and into
the foggy ground so they have like flash
bulbs you know like in their stomach
area and they're like ah it's really hot
ah it's relaxing there and their back
like if they were to turn they would
look like the Ninja Turtles oh giant
battery cuz they have like the battery
they have like the whole pack on on
their back right and each one of them
has a Detonator if you will like in
their hand I I saw the guy on the left
there he squeezes a trigger in his right
hand as they see the light on the back
of the guy in front of them they squeeze
theirs and it goes all the way through
cool this looks really good because
they're combining those real flashlights
for the heat sources and then the only
effect that's happening is just those
painted on Orange Lines but most of the
work is being done by the bright lights
cuz they look so real yeah this is a
great application of combining the
effects with practical oh and the face
melt of course how exactly did they do
that it was different kinds of wax right
and they're just filming it melt over
time is a bunch of like mixtures of
bunch of crap that they're layering over
18 hours it took them to layer all this
and get it ready to shoot and it's like
two industrial heaters on this guy the
effects guy's got like a little blow
dryer for spot jobs if he needs to trim
up a little thing here and there so is
it stop motion or are they filming it
it's a time lapse um I think it was like
over 10 minutes or so I think they were
saying too they had such bigger plans
for that shot too like the eyes were
supposed to suck back and like it was
supposed to be a whole thing and I think
he was pretty bummed with it but steel
was bu the effects guy the effects guy
and the shots almost ruined by the
glasses I know I noticed that too almost
it's a it's the perfect tell that this
is fast forwarded cuz they don't fall at
the regular speed like if they are
filming it they it falls fast forwarded
and the fact that the slow rotation I'm
like
a that's tough but here's the thing no
one's looking at the glasses everyone's
looking at his face turning red yeah
fair and you have a bunch of other
beautiful movement the Hat slowly
lowering the brow melting the eyes
losing their detail and becoming white
as they roll back in the head those guys
are magicians those practical effects
guys man they they just know tricks for
everything that they're trying to do
like Temple of Doom will get into some
of the lava stuff oh man lava super cool
oh I just remembered I saw a cut of the
loaded questions episode you're in it's
pretty good dude I want see it I want to
see it oh we should tell him what it is
though so you guys know the interview
show hot ones well we wanted to try a
new twist in the format so we had a show
called loaded questions where instead of
spicy chicken wings it's a roll of film
and we have't told that roll of film is
empty to ask a person questions and the
person who's being interviewed is one
taking pictures that roll of film okay
this might be something right here I
basically just got to wander around my
favorite place and he asked me a bunch
of like deep questions and it got real
spooky what what
the Deep insights interesting pictures
and a poignant captivating Mirror On
which you can reflect upon your journey
through
life I've promising big things but it's
actually really good Jonah's been
killing it so check it out in cord
digital.com all right enough of this
Jones let's look at that Jones enough Mr
Jones let's look at Dr Jones I can be a
doctor I can be a doctor one day now
let's get out of here right all of
us so Temple of Doom is actually a
prequel it takes place place before the
first movie yeah a year I didn't know
that until this morning me too when I
watched it yesterday I didn't know that
until right
now I think we got a big problem Dr Jo
shorty Dr Joe no more hey it's the dude
from everything everywhere all at
once that is crazy to me like what what
an odd career look at this shot by the
way look at
this that actually fell out of a real
airplane dude wait are there people in
that dude
wait no way that's a
dummy what a shot like wow what a what a
shot right I was sitting there I was
like what they're doing this what even
if it's a miniature even if it's dummies
they the camera AC it like they aced the
shot it's such a long shot yeah like is
it going to inflate is it going to
inflate
there's people in there and they just
they play the whole thing out it lands
and it
lands like think about this you're like
oh this is wacky they're going to save
themselves on a freaking little blowup
raft yeah right and then they do it they
do it and they show you the whole thing
uncut it's insane you want to see the
heart rip Nico yeah I want to see the
heart R take a look at the heart let's
take that look at that whole scene
actually let's like us take to the top
of that
scene did ren when's the last time
you've seen this as a kid all right get
ready let me put it this way I don't
remember this
[Applause]
shot how is he still alive
magic that's pretty cool what hold up
Burger I feel like the obvious thing
here is that they have him doing that on
his real chest they cut away they come
back to a dummy chest pause on that and
it matches pretty well but you can tell
it's different like the lighting is a
little different the texture of the skin
is a little different what I don't
understand is does he rip it is there
like a pre-scored yeah that he just like
kind of punctures through he just pushes
right through that latex like behind the
cast of the dude's chest they have like
two two pieces of metal like reverse
like accordion out it's like it opens up
it goes like that right and he gets his
hand in there they time it up right and
then it heals up afterwards which is a
really cool effect yeah that's what I
didn't understand this burger meat thing
it's just reverse shot he's opening up
the little accordion thing behind the
latex torso oh which is ripping it yeah
cuz that was the thing that got me is
that it actually reformed not just like
pushed back
together that lava looks so good you see
that that crusty stuff on the surface
yeah it's like looking in a ren Soul
yeah so this
swirling yeah that's a cool shot in the
ilm stages they built out a 30t shaft
they have a miniature cage miniature guy
for these over the shoulder shots going
down but for the actual lava itself it
ended up being like glycerin and a other
concoction of goopy texture it's almost
like hand lotion kind of a texture
that's going through all these pumps
these industrial pumps and they are
throwing in all this Cork and plastic
and chunks to give you all that crusty
Rock bits right okay and then because
the filtration system can't handle the
chunks they have to scoop it all out
from underneath and filter out they have
all these guys like filtering out all
the crap from this like hand lotion mix
and then sending it back up for them to
Chuck it back in all being lit from
underneath right it gives you that nice
glow coming up right and they said that
they had like 15 10K lights like the
brightest hottest lights and it was like
125° down there for these guys for weeks
just Just sh shoving chunks into lotion
for like I'm like God engine ship in the
Titanic but instead of coal it's lotion
and filtering chunks yeah yeah
exactly hey but check out the sick
bridge collapse oh this bridge scene is
awesome
yeah oh man man
wow
incredible
wow holy crap that was that had to be a
dummy right like but you know how his
are you looking at real people and
dummies in the same shot like what I
know is that they did the bridge claps
for real all of those are dummies and
they're all like pneumatic dummies oh to
get that all the air is like going
through them and like they're flailing
right oh interesting okay so they've got
like some sort of like Air Canister
inside of the dummy and then like on
action they like open it so then it's
like like when you have a hose and it's
turned on it's going like exactly
exactly so they're all like the
inflatable air guys basically same thing
wow it's such why don't they use that
use that anymore it looks so good they
like literally they just don't use that
in movies ever cuz why when it's so much
easier and cheaper to do a CG double
yeah but they still use dummies like why
not just use a Pneumatic
dummy but then there's that shot where
those guys fall off and they they're
Falling Towards the distance looks to be
a comp shot some sort of mat painting
down below them but they seem to be
rotoscoped but then they just keep
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
yeah those guys I know for a fact are
stop motion puppets stop motion yep on a
motion control arm that's pulling Mo
from camera it's basically the same
effect as Millennium Falcon going into
hypers speed but it's a guy
going he goes away from camera oh okay
eternal life Dr Jones The Gift of Youth
to whoever drinks from The Grail all
right so now we are looking at the third
Indiana Jones movie Temple of Doom noers
of the Lost AR no no Last Crusade
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull Last
Crusade dial of Destiny Last Crusade oh
okay we are looking at the Last Crusade
this is the Last Crusade that's what I
said only in the leap from the lion's
head they prove his
worth Possible Oh is he in there yeah
yeah oh yeah boom so cool so look CG I'm
pretty sure it's just printed out paper
so it looks CG because it just looks
uncanny right cuz perspective is skewing
but he's comped
in he was comped in there yeah you see
his feet slide yeah this is a motion
control this is the Lord of the Rings
style miniature and foreground character
yeah okay I see it now I didn't see it
at first cuz I was looking at the bridge
that's a miniature that we're looking at
on the back wall there apparently the
guy painting that bridge he had the
footage projected onto the top of the
bridge while looking at the Viewpoint of
the camera right he's painting painting
and then yeah reveal the trick motion
control arm come back around and then
this little bit here they just had this
on black he faked like he he didn't
actually throw they look like salt
crystals you can tell it kind of feels
like it's making it brighter this that's
over yeah so what's going on there it's
just two pieces of film being stacked on
top of each other so you're ending up
with less exposure through your negative
there that's all is happening it's basic
basically screen mode if you ever have
composited a lightsaber or a muzzle
flash they're basically just doing the
same thing with brightly lit rocks
otherwise you have to like blue scen it
which is a huge process being able to
just shine light through the bright
parts and Expo like overexpose your film
there is way easier but things tend to
be transparent so you have to be careful
so we've actually looked at this movie a
ton in a previous episode at the end of
this video we'll have a link to a
playlist with all those videos the
original films are Classics now n's
about to throw a little salt on the two
most recent Indiana Jones films but
first let me tell you about today's
sponsor raycon wow guys it's already
February 2024 years flying by that means
Valentine's Day is coming up now now no
matter what your relationship status is
or how you feel about Valentine's Day in
general you got to admit some things
just fit better together peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches Indiana Jones and
his whip you know what else is also a
perfect match raycon and your everyday
routine it is crazy that these things
are called the everyday earbuds because
I literally wear them every day whether
that's in the gym which is my favorite
place to wear them or just out and about
in the world they are some of the best
earbuds you can get and I'm going to
tell you why raycons have optimized gel
tips for the perfect in ear fit these
earbuds are so comfortable they actually
stay in your ears seriously running
lifting in the gym moving around they
are not falling out just like Indiana
Jones he never knows when he's going to
get a break to relax with some of his
favorite Tunes so luckily these babies
have 8 hours of playtime and a 32-hour
battery life Indiana's also a very
honorable guy you know he's always
finding crazy Treasures a lot of gold
but he's never taking it he's always
donating it to museums luckily he
doesn't have to worry about that extra
cash because raycons are half the price
of other premium audio Brands and they
have all the regular features that you
would expect out of a premium earbud
three customized sound profiles earbud
tap functions noise isolation but also
awareness mode unfortunately this
awesome technology never made it to the
Indiana Jones timeline but if it did
Indiana Jones would tell you to go to
byy ron.com crew to get 15% off your
order plus free shipping all right so
you guys got salty Sam last week now
it's Nico's turn back to
react Legend says that a crystal skull
was stolen from a mythical lost city in
the Amazon this is Indiana Jones 4 it
came out 19 years after the previous
installment and I think there was a big
technological jump between those you
could say that I mean this is basically
hot off the heels of George Lucas
finishing the Star Wars prequel trilogy
this is one of those things like the
movie was not very well received
notoriously not well received it's
there's a lot of weird Jank in it which
is Bittersweet and sad because Spielberg
and George Lucas and Harrison Ford like
the team came back and so it's like in
your heart you're like you want want it
to be
good but it's really rough a lot of
parts so we're going to take a look at
this one scene here which has a
combination of some really cool
practical stuff some CGI stuff and
nothing encapsulates that more than the
fridge scene in Indiana Jones 2 1
zero whoa sick that was actually
cool is a miniature
town they did the town for real they did
the town for real they did a crazy
practical effect here boom it's freaking
rad it's amazing it looks awesome and
the footage of it is super cool it's all
Air cannons by the way there's an air
cannon in each house and boom boom boom
boom boom in sequence wa doing the shock
wave like they have all this reality
around them and then there's so much
unreality okay you got to do some
extensions cool I get it you got a cop
in the background all good I get it but
then they're like oh but we also need to
add the smoke from the stuff being
burned and they're like oh we're
starting to get into digital town and
then they just they break physics again
and they have a second shock wave hit
before the actual shock wave hits wait
is this not the shock wave well there's
the real shock wave but you'll notice
there's a second shock wave that hits
right before the big shock wave hits
right there Z oh you're having animators
come in and start to spruce up the shot
in a way that's not physically accurate
so it's already feeling animated but
then this they slow it down and you get
notice the interpolation you get frame
interpolation and it makes everything
look smeary it makes it all look
undefined it makes it look like cheap
visual effects it makes look like
there's a visual effects artist who ran
out of time and has to hide everything
behind motion blur and Haze and Bloom
yeah but I don't think that's a visual
effects problem I think that's like a
stylistic like the director wanted a
certain look type problem well yeah it's
like I'm not trying to like I'm not
blaming like a visual effects artist
like screwing up a shot that's that's
not what's happening here this is a like
it just it's like all these things are
fighting each other and then you have
shots like this car which there's a lot
of hand animation you can feel like the
fake camera shake and this fake lens
flares dude wait wait it didn't show the
fridge getting launched it just showed
the fridge there's an old guy in that
fridge by the
way no no he's just like
this he's not getting tossed he's like
this right so he's good he's good from a
physics standpoint none of this makes
any sense like that fridge nothing can
go faster than the shock wave it's not
like the shock wave hit the fridge like
a baseball bat hitting a ball that's not
how it works the the shock wave is
literally pushing everything outwards
faster than anything else could possibly
move none of this is based in reality
and and then of course the fact that
like there's a dude in
there like you said yeah rcing himself
and we're all okay with a littleit of
unreality but like what are you guys
trying to do with the visual effects
here are you trying to be painterly and
you know go crazy and make a cool mat
painting here are you trying to make it
feel like this is real cuz it's
definitely nobody's following physical
rules here look at that dim lens flare
over his head as he's climbing up the
hill from the Sun like you can't have a
lens flare be at 10% exposure in your
shot it just it physically does not make
sense and this movie struggles a lot
with this you know you guys know the
monkey
scene okay you have real footage of an
actor but like there's so much fake
Bloom and fake glow and like you know
what it is I don't know if they're
trying to hide mistakes I think that's
it I think that's it I think it's like
guys this doesn't this kind of looks
pretty bad and they're like what can we
do like well let's Bloom it up let's
flare it up let's do something let's
smear it up to like hide the fact that
this isn't quite working I I will say
one last thing one one philosophical
thing here when you're working with
constraints especially like
technological constraints you can't just
write anything you want in a script when
you write something you have to think
about how you're going to shoot it and
how you're going to pull it off this
movie feels like somebody just wrote a
script with whatever they wanted in it
and then they shot the movie just
following the script and everybody's
everybody's doing their best in all
their individual departments but it's
not under that single cohesive vision of
somebody that's writing with visual
effects in mind and special effects in
mind and cinematography in mind and you
know that whole stack of creativity
isn't really living within one person it
doesn't feel like it is why are you
chasing the thing that drove your father
crazy so they took another crack at
it and I've never I have never seen this
movie yeah so this is the intro to the
movie so I know you guys looked at the
Young Indiana Jones in a previous
episode again we'll link all this at the
end of the video but this was a big
question mark on the movie you talk
about like going into a scene not really
knowing how they're going to handle it
this is the epitome of
that who this is so insane wao yeah this
is the best daging I've ever seen in my
entire life it's pretty good you've
never seen this Clint no so yeah so
Clint hasn't seen any of this these are
fresh reactions you know what's crazy is
that like it's still I can still subtly
see the CGI once in a while there shots
that are perfect they truly perfect
exactly and it's so good that I can't
exactly say how it's not perfect exactly
so what's insane to me is just the scale
of this entire sequence it's one thing
to pull off Harrison Ford looking
younger and having it be photoreal and
believable but have that be the case for
25 minutes of a movie through multiple
different types of scenes he's in an
action sequence here get
down but like through this whole action
sequence every single shot that's like
half a second long has a perfectly DED
Harrison Ford yeah it's like the scale
of the sequence blows my mind funny
thing is they kind of want you to forget
too it's like ideally you just
completely slip into watching the
movie oh wait okay one of the okay one
of the hardest hits I've ever seen is
coming up I'm ready oh this guy's going
to get clocked
To the victor go the
spoils
wait wait what
wait your whole life came up to this
moment Ren you had vict goil you had
buil up for that yeah you're really
talking that
up the sickest heart to the there we go
there okay now it's coming up now it's
coming up that wasn't the
[Laughter]
hit
dude oh
man clobber dude that was that was the
hit I was talking about oh man that that
was so anticlimactic earlier that was so
funny that had to have been like an
insanely expensive process
just because of how much work had to be
involved you broke down exactly how they
did this in in that previous episode but
to like summarize what's like the one
sentence summary of how they did this
this is guesswork they used the Irishman
triple camera rig to capture his face
using infrared cameras to triangulate it
and get a 3D mesh which then used to
grab his animations and map it onto a CG
model which they then also ran through a
bunch of fancy fancy deep fix stuff to
give it the extra bump of realism yeah
like that looks perfect this I have
literally no notes it looks Flawless to
me it's crazy it's just that he's not
emoting as much as I feel like he would
be if he didn't have that they didn't
have that restriction you know and
there's still a little bit of that like
high frequency detail that deep fakes
and CG models lack yeah like this guy
here like watching that guy talk look at
his neck and how the collar is catching
on his skin a little bit and stretching
it you get the wrinkles in those
directions and as he moves the skin
folds underneath his chin kind of fold
up on each other there's volume and
there's physics happening and you can't
quite get this close to deep fakes and
if you look at Harrison Ford you'll
notice like stuff like that's just a
little clean it's Skin's not getting
pulled or stretched that strap isn't
doing anything to his skin you know
everything's just like lightly on there
you can't quite get in this close
because stuff like the skin being pulled
on the collar like that and just the
volume of Flesh and how it moves and
squishes and all that kind of stuff
that's where things start to break down
and you avoid it yeah but I'm still just
so impressed with like how he looked
there oh don't get me wrong this is the
best face replacement in the world
oh yeah oh yeah don't get me wrong but
this is just you see where the
limitations are and where you have to be
careful with it my biggest takeaway from
watching this movie is just like it
looks so expensive I feel like Crystal
Skull it was the first time they really
did any sort of digital on that sort of
thing and so all the action sequences
were much faster paced but they lost all
that tangibility and I think this movie
they went back to doing the same method
but trying to do it so much better that
they regained some of that tangibility
and it was hit or miss for me wait Clint
what are you doing today dude I am live
streaming at this very second the very
next 3D Community challenge come on over
to my channel if you guys have watched
VFX come on over and let us do some VFX
it's going to be a good time on the pure
Channel let's do it cool all right bye
[Music]
everybody see you